[Musica]
siamo ritornati nella parte strana
dell'internet ed a tutti i ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo video sono fan ejei e
liceo su taxus e ho subito di che si
tratta allora play point livello 1 con
la papera bene
ehi guarda caso siamo le anime delle
papere sei l'ultimo di noi
beh meno male di trovare le uova e
portarle al sicuro per favore prendi
questo decoder cerri mai accadere adesso
puoi lasciare un commento
e vero a rai e quindi sono una papera
che cammina grazie livello 0 con cui i
lavori ragazzi ho fatto difficile non
solo nello 2 complete o jump fin qua e
là tra complete
quindi si può dare a ok ok ok il dash
serve per bellissimo e tv un super meat
boy con una papera senza un motivo è
nata logico lo è i contanti salti che
fai per farti sentire uno strozzino ne
vai tanti va bene no ho sbagliato puoi
lasciare anche in alto ottimo bella e
giocata pro gamer ragazzi giocato
talmente tanti cagate nella mia vita del
genere che ormai a partire dai wanna be
the gates non si sono ricordate che a
questo punto siamo arrivati allo stremo
e non mi stupisce più nulla padon ormai
proprio bra trovate su croate cioè
proprio io sto gioco l'ho fatto
praticamente non è però detto stack
regata ti dice anche più o meno dove vai
a finire quando da sci ok madonna a due
ore che fa sta roba attenzione che qua
il bello è che non esistono checkpoint
quindi se se tu muori mori non è che poi
fa niente mori ottima sta roba
quindi ok a posto l'importante a non
morire quindi va bene ragazzi sono
apparsi complicate le faccende qua e
proprio adesso e il tutto fattibile
ecco allora crede di aver trovato un
ottimo sequel che mario è super meat boy
soprattutto perché da quando non è
uscita ragazzi super meat boy due
riuscirà ad aprire le all'anno scorso è
quasi passato un anno c'è super meat boy
ha preso la quarantena seriamente
dall'anno scorso preme quindi dobbiamo
arrangiarci con delle dei surrogati di
super meat boy che però non sono per
niente male a questo punto dire lo sai
che sono anche meglio ma che tutto
questo dove stiamo andando a fini cioè
ci sarà un un check point prima o poi ce
della serie ok è finito la mappa alle
sociali qui c'è questa nuova no cioè
l'ultima così ficano fici il gioco ciò
che questo va bene non c'è una storia
non c'è niente c'è una papera che da cha
va bene ma basta a quanti ce ne sono
ancora
se veramente non c'è c'è poi manco a
pagarlo e la roba incredibile apple
ok
ma che hai fatto chi poteva darle game
sta roba comunque vorrei di michele
casinò devi accendere tutti e tre porca
vacca difficilissimo a ciò è fatta a
maledizione è troppo difficile ma dai
vai a cagare la golden share lì non
serve a niente
addio cioè fatto ci ho fatto una parola
perché laddove ancora morire trova
niente
ok occhio questo è difficile ragazzi
[Musica]
proprio lui è veramente l'hanno
costruito per farti diventare si stupì
questo giorno veramente bacon sapevo
maledizione alla vita a tec.it ha creato
porca vacca chi non ti metti chiamato
tax ohlins in tutto questo dove sei una
papera con evidenti problemi di
relazione con le persone come faccio
madonna
ho rischiato da o abbiamo cambiato
almeno fisionomia dei livelli live
eastwood answer la vita è dannatamente
corta quanto d'andata l'inter ero ok
soprattutto la vita di questa papera
porca vacca lo sapevo la gente che gioca
doom 3 io gioco a tax office ragazzi del
menti di conto ragazzi sono stati
veramente difficili livelli aiuto prima
erano facili sti adesso c'è un problema
di fondo quanto tempo spiega mi devo
andare sotto aprire tornare giù dopo il
casino una donna fatto una roba
allucinante poi se muoio riparto da zero
quello fatto no no non posso essere
molto così con un demente non posso
essere molto così come un demente non
posso essere morto come un demente dai
ragazzi dai ma cosa ho fatto
perfetto ok piano papera di merda sembra
facile
non lo è ve lo dico io voto fatto una
giocata incredibile perché non me lo
spiego che ho fatto è difficile spiegare
parco del demonio morto porto del
demonio morto ok la testata ho dato la
testata una granata e fini bile suo
gioco c'è cultura l'ha mai finito e non
retro me non e fini nessun ordine ha
dichiarato a visto cioccolato è talmente
assurdo ora devo fare un casino devo
correre perfetto non così però ce l'ho
fatta
casino meno ma ragazzi finisco sto mondo
e posso smettere per cortesia perché sta
diventando problematica la situazione
parte in ogni modo ci sono delle nuove
features per questa cosa mi piace di
soggiorno ma dovuto fatto quota pro
player trovi sia l'ultimo conosco il
kung fu va bene zio grazie vengono detto
non di meno senza ok
difficile ok
meravigliosa allora fermi ok no ok ok
bellissimo ma non è finita oddio quel
successo ho sbagliato perché a ok ampio
progetto era giusto che lasciare non era
giunto nella sbagliato però forse devo
correre basta perfetto con le cose e ora
ma devo saltare li tornare indietro e
come lo centro ma come faccio love e dai
ragazzi
favi seri come faccio a centrare quella
roba lì come come dovrei spiegami dio
dio lavorando io veramente sei l'unico
gioco che mi fa cristo nar e questo è
veramente lato di dark souls 15 gradi
tutti i due giochi di fano che come ho
fatto come mi sono salvato non è
possibile
ok meno ma meno male tra l'altro vera
intervista era assurda altro che super
meat boy ma cos'è sta roba
se l'ha fatto satana in persona ha
programmato lui suo gioco ma che
problemi ci è stato fatto poi di male io
ne volevo fare una provata ma ha fatto
una cagata
ok molto easy molto tranquillo avuto
inizio
possiamo cambiare ora cavalca che mai
c'era il tasto 20 possiamo cambiare
livello perché mi sta veramente sbando
ecco non so se si è capito vorrei
veramente cambiare livello ragazzi se
possibile quanto dura ancora st purga no
io io vera mio voglio yo yo yo yo yo ma
guarda io non so cosa dire non so cosa
dire ma guarda se moriva un'altra volta
così per bellissimo fatto una cosa
incredibile come aiuto bravo doha ma
l'eni che abbiamo mai allora sono
stupido sono stupido non è possibile
devo morire perché sono stupido perché
non ho capito che funziona la mia vita
di me perché io veramente che sarà
veramente semplice riuscito a fare una
cagata colossale di sul finale che uno
diceva come è battuto per niente che
sono stupido vabbè dai mai capito se va
beh
volete far diventare dovete far
diventare stupido oggi ragazzi va bene
ci ho messo quattro ore per accendere
sti cosi che non ancora acceso porca
vacca
ok vederli morire adesso li fa perfetto
e cattorini cosa devo fare qua
ok non lo saprei di fare quindi meglio
che non muoio meno male perché non avrei
saputo di farlo con lo giuro
meno male che sono non mi vedo ok che
adesso mi vedo solo che è morto allora
allora allora ok ottimo forse perché
sono d'altra parte non lo camion a 6
grafica ma cosa ho fatto che provata
quando resta purga infernale di livelli
gialli bellissimo belli madonna sono
stato un proprio adesso
adesso no allora questo è l'ultimo
questo è l'ultimo perché lo vedo di
difficoltà estrema e non credo di
riuscire a farlo in realtà neanche pro
proviamoci
[Musica]
basta basta basta basta parlarne si
spense spendi spendi spegne signori
spero che vi sia piaciuto concludo qua
per motivi personali vado a casa che
sono malato io voglio veramente porre
fine alla mia esistenza adesso ti
ringrazio per aver visto questo game
place vado molto orgoglioso di questo
questo video particolarmente quindi
grazie proprio vi diciamo il ragazzino
si deve procedere con ti piace chiedere
giustizia e noi ci vediamo come sempre
al prossimo video difesa ragazze
[Musica]